[Music]
okay
welcome to the creek in the cave a few
things before we get started please stay
off your cell phones no hecklinger Cube
table talk to him now now who's ready
for other people
you love them get up to your house
welcome to other people
the smooth sultry tones of royalty-free
Music we start our show
uh my name is Hans Kim I am a dating
expert one of the top daters out there
uh hopefully uh someone signs up because
we don't currently we don't have a show
so we need somebody to sign up anybody
everyone wants to watch no one wants to
do it oh swiggy's swiggy's in the bucket
he has thrown down the gauntlet uh my
name is Hans Kim I have kissed many
people on a show called kill Tony it's a
kind of a big deal thank you sir
a guy that just found the internet knows
kill Tony
and none of the rest of you do
um ketchup millennials
uh but yes we need women now we have
plenty of men
we know we just need a woman to sign on
up we got an amazing front row here
and not much else it's a thin layer it's
like 300 right now you guys are holding
back the Persians uh but anyways let's
bring up the guests tonight the guest is
gonna help me do the thing his name is
funny comedian Jordan Shelby
Jordan Jordan Jordan
[Music]
here he is Jordan Shelby thank you how's
it going it's going great how's your day
been Jordan good uh it's been good I um
Everybody Hans Kim is a dating expert
thank you and I know that because he
[ __ ] me so
yes we [ __ ] and that's why I'm here
yes I'm the top someone else that we
have more than one time we got one woman
thank you so much I wonder who it is I
can't we all know it's a 50 50 chance
that you're gonna go on a date with
swiggy so those are the kind of things
that we have to offer anyone can sign up
even you sir you can sign up you can
show everyone your NPR beard that you
grew during the pandemic
um yeah we uh we just did a little tour
the three sold out shows one sort of
sold out and one one half sold out show
yeah I can't see past the first row here
is it packed out yes it is okay a good
day to be myopic
we got lots of dudes now
fun tour we no one oh there it is a wet
bucket tonight
[Music]
just like the ladies hopefully
we play our cards right straight
I remember last time is this the gay
bucket no the gay bucket's empty the the
gay bug gets bone dry okay remember last
time when you called two people from the
gay bucket and it was a gay man and a
lesbian yes and it wasn't funny the
whole time
that was cool let's see let's do it I
thought I thought it was enjoyable it
was actually great yeah uh the next guy
coming up is Chad oh
Chad Chad
that's how you say Chad in Spanish
and the woman coming up is named Emma
Emma yes the woman the one and only
woman we have tonight
we're gonna dry this out a little bit
get it nice and dry for the ladies
that's how they like
here's Chad uh here's Shadow Emma Shadow
Emma just took a seat after I called her
nose
she's like enough work for me
[Music]
I don't think so Chad everyone loves you
yeah she would never do that shadow and
and Emma going on a date for one minute
and then we interview you starting now
one minute hi tadow nice to meet you
nice to meet you Dale are you from here
no I'm from New York oh really you just
get here
two months ago oh really okay yeah are
you from here no nobody's from here
yeah where are you from I just got here
from Arizona nice now uh did you get
here for work or just just chill living
life for two months
okay okay that's cool teacher I don't
know are you a fan of magic
yes I love magic oh really
I might uh do you know how to do magic
or you might do something let me see her
name
let me see if I can
do a little something with your name
here now
you can uh
I'm here
but that was just for your name
anybody see that okay sorry I don't
wanna yeah that took a lot of a lot in
there for me that's hard for me to do
very impressive thank you and time give
it up for a shadow yes and Emma wow I
love a magic trick that ends with a good
apology yeah yeah sorry position I am I
apologize that was great you did a magic
trick and then you had no confidence in
it immediately I I I I was I was like oh
this is my first time to ever do magic
and yeah no that was your first time
ever now imagine it's terrible
I would like it to be yes
yes well unfortunately it won't be if
you want to get laid anytime soon okay
there we go I'm gonna have to dip into
the old Sorting Hat is that a condom
behind your ear no it's the Harry Potter
I thought that was hot I thought that
was sexy as [ __ ] yeah what was sexy
about it
um the fact that he's missing a tooth on
the right side thank you I appreciate
that yeah that was sexy can you make
that come back is that true
those are for my good old rolling days
rolling yeah not wearing a mouth guard
with Jiu Jitsu and oh you did Jiu Jitsu
yeah someone put you in a little tooth
hold yeah no it hit knees with faces
it's not fun yeah
yeah well you know what are you gonna do
you're out here being a badass rolling
around Jiu Jitsu and Magic that's yeah
yeah I can tie you up something
have you ever used magic during the Jiu
Jitsu match
I wish I could make that guy's boner
disappear that was in my back that was
that was a bad time you had a bat a dude
boner yeah in my back like during a
match that was not a fun time wow at
least it wasn't in the back hole it
definitely it was definitely a good
maneuver because it distracted me from a
lot of a lot of things I was trying to
get away from the dick more than him all
those feelings in your body yeah it was
it was very confusing time for me
anyways Emma you are here for two months
they're just chilling out you're having
a good time what made you come to a
dating show of all things
was looking for something to do with my
Sunday evening why not go out and meet
some strange men
is this the first time uh I was weird
has this the first time a man has ever
done magic for you
um I think so you think you remember
probably right like in that in this
context yes definitely I've seen a
magician before though that was a man he
was doing magic for the whole audience
yeah not specifically me that's cool it
did it feel different when it's
specifically for you
no not that particular very enchanting
if there isn't any magic in the air
tonight it's fine I'm trying different
things what are you the David Blaine
thing where you put a metal thing
through your arm
I do that once I think that's we can all
do that you can't do it sustainably yeah
yeah
uh so that's cool you got what uh what
do you think about the men in Austin so
far
um I've had a few really shitty dates
and I've kind of let that paint the
whole picture for me well that's a good
way to do it yeah yeah just let a few
things influence
your judgment on the whole city yeah
what was so shitty about it what was
like did they say something weird like
did they try to do magic for you
yeah that was the second most weird
thing whoa what was the weirdest thing
um I mean
kind of like
a lot of
forceful body language just who he was
yeah as a person was the weirdest thing
on a date with Tony Robbins yeah exactly
he's doing a power pose
that's cool uh yeah just a reminder this
going out Live on YouTube so I'm glad
that wasn't terribly like a horrible
answer or anything but yeah I mean if
there's any personal details you'd like
to leave out
this person but you know so what does
powerful body language can you do like
an example of what he was doing that was
so weird weirder than Magic
um I mean he does a lot of like
so a lot of like
what is that like mocking me walking
down the street yeah
yeah a good old mock
um he would yeah I mean he was not short
but shorter than he said he was on his
dating profile oh
how many inches shorter was he
too in disorder is that a general thing
that men do it's like two is that about
average two inches shorter than yeah
yeah I'd say so I always say ages yeah
eight inches damn Shadow is working with
magic again yeah
foreign
up to your dick make it look wider yeah
what do you think the sexiest magic
trick would be
dick widening is pretty good
I'm gonna make my penis disappear
I have no idea I'm Chatta that's more a
question for Chatta what is the sexiest
magic trick do you think what is the
sexiest form of magic I think uh
when I was a kid I watched David
Copperfield make a woman float over
water and it was very wet and very
sensual and he wrapped him wrapped
around him she was getting sprayed by
water yeah it was over water it was very
sexy that was that was my most sexy
goggles magic yeah I jerked off to that
why well that's all I had I was like 14
that part oh sorry I might be autistic
I know you're autistic you did Magic
yeah that's true
I'm a 42 year old on a date
are you okay yeah I am that's cool Emma
do you have any like things like that
that you could do on a date like magic
no no
no okay I can sing really badly but like
oh it's only suitable if you're at a
karaoke bar I'd say what's your goat
um
Wannabe by the Spice Girls okay you are
white yeah
happy to confirm that for you not I
don't know what that meant well yeah I
mean Shadow Can Do Magic you can sing
Spice Girls it's gonna have like the
shittiest uh Cruise entertainment night
ever
Carnival you can also defend defend her
he could distract someone with magic and
then choke them out which is kind of
cool yeah there you go yeah he's got one
less tooth as long as they don't put
their dick in his back yeah that's his
Kryptonite yeah foreign
so what ended up happening with the dude
with his dick on your back uh I ended up
choking him but uh yeah I had I had to
get rear position I was not let him have
it anymore yeah I tried it again on top
of it yeah sit on it no it was not too
much it was a lot I'll tell you yeah
some people get excited yeah it was a
lot more than I was expecting was he
embarrassed or was he like oh he was
like yeah let's go that's who I am yeah
he was ready yeah maybe like took Viagra
just for this like it was like ready
yeah that seems like a like a health
hazard it might snap it or something
he wasn't wearing a cup no usually with
the rolling matches like a geezy don't
wear cups like I didn't wear mouth
guards or cups yeah yeah just went in
raw dog it yeah have you seen those
monks that kick each other in the nuts
really hard yeah point where it's numb
and they I don't know actually what the
benefit is now that I'm saying but it
looks cool yeah it looks cool it's like
a cool thing to do on a date yeah
would that be attractive to you Emma if
if you went on a date with a man who's
like kick me and that's as hard as you
can it won't even hurt not even a little
bit
yeah actually you know I think that's
what's missing from this yeah I have
seen videos of that where they step on
it with Stilettos and [ __ ] have you seen
no it's a king thing I've not seen that
I have not been to your Jiu Jitsu
matches yeah yeah you should definitely
come sometime they're fun
stilettos balls and dicks in your back
oh yeah
that's the name of his new album that's
my book title
so Emma what do you do for a living
I do Tech Consulting
and what would you tell if you had to
Tech consult for shadow would you tell
him
what do you need your Salesforce
application to do
I need automatic emails uh
yeah I need reminders
no
hey chatter what is your day job
um I do a lot of different things I'm a
writer uh but I uh I sell cannabis
classes and cannabis products online
you sell cannabis you say classes yeah I
teach uh people how to work in the
Cannabis industry to get it's like a
driver's ed it makes driver's ed videos
for Stoners yeah
how to smoke a bong yeah we do a live
class once a month and yeah do that kind
of thing yeah sometimes I'll go to the
dispensaries but since I've been here
it's been mostly Zoom well if you had to
teach Emma how to smoke a bong how would
you tell her yeah
just relax and let it happen whoa oh
wait wait I feel like I'm at your Jiu
Jitsu match again
it's also not how you smoke a bong it
won't work you should definitely relax
when you're inhaling
don't don't fight it let it just go Let
It Go like a dick in your back yeah
exactly
anyways Emma so what is uh your next
step in uh Austin dating scene are you
gonna like maybe go paddle boarding next
summer
I'm doing that after this but oh tonight
you're gonna go do some ice fishing in
the freezing cold yeah that's cool are
you like from Canada or something
[Music]
uh close enough I'm from upstate New
York oh yeah the worst part of New York
so the rest of it right did they give
that like six and a half foot of snow
oh recently you watched the news I was
aware of it that they uh they got lost
now yeah and uh what kind of news were
you watching well when they step on your
balls with Stilettos
Shadow is a comedian by the way there's
no laughs you could definitely tell
the effort is there that's cool I take
it for a uh MSNBC kind of guy
business [ __ ]
right now
well swiggy's in there yeah swiggy's in
there we got a whole another woman yeah
holy [ __ ]
the show just doubled in excitement
please sign up
we need you yeah please do please sign
up Emma how's it how does it feel being
a woman hmm
I love it every day of my life what an
answerable question
she's loving it being a woman is like
McDonald's have you done the paddle
boarding date in Austin yet no I have
not no I bet Chad Chad oh have you done
the paddle boarding date I have not
ES
I haven't done either I'm wondering what
it's like seems a little uncomfortable
yeah I'm like walls yeah I like to be
all walls on a date I would like some
[ __ ] uh boundary between me and death
just cold water yeah
yeah Shadow what's the most uh athletic
thing you did besides getting your tooth
knocked out
yeah I wanted to be a cage fighter I
tried that for a while but uh how far
did you get uh to the cage and you were
like I'm turning back yeah it was bad
you don't like to get punched in the
face for 500 bucks that's not that's not
a fun time yeah yeah some people do it
for free yeah well that's true I did it
for free for a while but
um my most athletic thing I've ever done
or recently or in life I was a soccer
player also well I developed asthma so I
don't know what that means the magic is
actually a good move because if you see
someone doing magic you're like I could
beat the [ __ ] out of this guy but then
he actually is a cage fighter yeah an
unsuccessful cage fighter that's
successful but good enough for a street
fights good yeah you can spring it on
him yeah have you ever got into a fight
I have when uh especially when you're
training like
um when you go like out with like a
bunch of big guys to a bar like the bar
locals will
want to fight you immediately like it's
just it's just like in their blood for
some reason so like any big dude walking
into a bar with a group of other big
dudes they just want to like antagonize
you and pick on you things like that so
yeah I know I do I deal with that all
the time like dude fellas there's enough
for all of you
you guys can all put your dicks in my
back yeah exactly uh Emma have you ever
gotten into a fight that was gonna be my
question
well would you like to chatto is a
trained assassin
not with a trained assassin no it's not
looking into a fight have you done
sports or what's your sport of choice
have you ever heard of Gaelic football
I think I just heard Shadow describe it
a little bit
it's an Irish sport that's
like a potato around yeah yeah actually
feed your family throw around the potato
skin that's cool so you tackle you're
out there tackling [ __ ] not quite
it's kind of like a mixture of soccer
and rugby but no tackling that makes
sense I don't know soccer touch or
anything do they freeze tag
uh no there's no like it's not stop and
go it's like
closer to soccer yeah but you use your
hands
so does Shadow yeah no I don't mean to
make our contestants be well
are you gonna ask Jordan well she kept
describing what it's not so I couldn't
really make sure the actual thing but I
know it isn't you use your hands and you
don't tackle each other yeah you just
like say scathing things like oh you
look good at anything
that's exactly it we have to do it with
an Irish accent Irish
I'm not going to do it uh the Temptation
is there that's cool are you Irish
I am well my parents are from Ireland
so is was that a Upstate New York thing
Gaelic football
more of like a
Suburban New York City I've never heard
greater area thing
they're like pretty limited to the Bronx
actually
that's perfect sport for the suburbs
yeah yeah no tackling
the blacks will get us if we allow that
shadow
what do you think who is uh have you are
you like racist at all have you dated a
lot of different people you prefer that
to me
I'm just wondering uh yeah I was uh when
I was 16 I worked at a Taco Mayo and my
manager was an African-American lady and
we uh were romantic in the uh the back
room one time okay I wonder I was
wondering where that was going I could
have gone either direction yeah so she's
a child molester though I guess but yeah
yeah but not really you're a dude yeah
but that's what I said yeah
that's cool so you uh you know you uh
you're an open you you'll take basically
anyone that's the that's why I'm here
man that's America for you that's the
freedoms we have oh that's cool uh Emma
I don't mean to sound like self-serving
but have you ever dated an Asian person
before
the answer is no
no what a surprise another white woman
that doesn't date Asians
um well what why not have you dated an
Asian person before yeah okay an Asian
woman but everyone that's yeah I don't
want to be an Asian dude
nice
I don't not date ASM people I just
haven't you just don't go to the library
enough for
Anime conventions she does work in tech
support
I know yeah I guess that's more Indian
she works in Tech
Consulting Consulting yeah yeah
I don't know I just haven't met the
right Asian today I guess
there's always the right Asian for
everyone there's a billion of us there's
got to be at least a couple white Asians
for everyone yeah I'm sure there is uh
Shadow what is your uh dating history
like
all of it yeah just like a most
memorable thing that's happened so I'll
be include you guys in my life real
quick I've been married for 23 years
and we're in an open relationship oh
you're married yeah so this is uh We've
uh We've we've gotten to the end of that
relationship you know now we're just
like [ __ ] it anybody anytime let's just
light this thing on fire yeah
so Emma he's sort of like uh like a one
of those hippies like how does that make
you feel like he's doing a liberal thing
that's awesome for for him not my speed
but that's cool that's why I usually
support you she all guys all day long oh
yeah your wife's in a [ __ ] up
relationship that's awesome got girls no
why don't you bring your wife along yeah
just bring yourself is this normally the
time where you tell your date that you
have a wife or yeah I try to do it up
front yeah yeah yeah because at the end
it's really weird when she's at home
watching TV and I'm like don't just
ignore her let's just go to the bedroom
that's just my wife
and are you telling your date that you
have a wife before or after you do magic
it depends how good the trick lands I
try to do it with the magic first let's
see how this goes yeah yeah yeah Queen
of Hearts just like my wife yeah
she's more of a three of Spades
is this your card and I have a wife I'm
just kidding she's great she really is
yeah I know we all know yeah that's why
you're with her uh Emma have you ever
been in an open relationship
um not knowingly oh a non-consensual
open relationship I'm a good guy I tell
you how to close that [ __ ] up
so that was a messy breakup
or are you still with him
I'm not still with him oh thank God
we're gonna have an intervention
um
that's too bad it was it uh is there uh
any funny stories that came out of it
um
I mean like kind of how obvious it was
it's kind of funny looking back on it
um how nice he had another girlfriend
and then he would also hit on all of my
friends when we were all together so
kind of tragic but I feel like he was
upfront about it then
yeah it's just not with words yeah but
with actions
yeah wow I'm sure there's a funny story
in there somewhere but it's hard to
track that's kind of funny that it was
hitting on everyone I'm sure he wasn't
successful most of the time that's what
it is you gotta play the odds man yeah
no he usually does not
well luckily chatto would never do that
he has a faithful wife that he has yeah
he's loyal to her and you yeah that's
yeah yeah I'm just looking for a second
I'm looking for a third or fourth you
know we're just keeping it right there
close close to the family third or
fourth
that's when you want a fifth or six
excuse getting weirder is it Chad Dash o
it's all one word capital O
really
no it's not that is his name is Chad and
his last name starts with o but
that's not what he said that's what I
know
I want to know what your name is you
creepy [ __ ] I follow you
anyways Emma has a real name and she's a
real person
what advice did you give to chatto about
his wife situation
she has no last name I don't think I
need
where does she know what's going on
she's watching the internet right now
like how can you hide this from her
she's watching the show she's a faithful
fan of the show she wants she wants Hans
I'm trying to get on here we're trying
to mix this thing up together no don't
be getting excited man
Shadow's wife
um yes I honestly might now if you can
help me out with Emma we can work this
out oh my God Emma is not a token to be
passed around she is a human being just
like your wife is let's go on a double
date so you bring him I'll bring your
wife there we go now we got it there it
is she's in for it
stop pointing to women please
[Laughter]
well do you think this couple can
actually make it or do you think like
Emma's too practical and shadows a
magician
um you know I something tells me this
isn't going to work out strangely yeah
maybe it's because Emma's been scooching
farther away the entire time yeah
or maybe it's Shadow's wife but I think
it will work out between you and
Shadow's wife that's obvious yeah I
haven't [ __ ] it up yet it's only
upward from here her name also end with
o it does no [ __ ] way her name is
Chata
it's like a Spanish thing yeah what race
is your wife uh she's as white as me a
white yeah so you like to keep it in the
race well now we're trying to mix it up
but you know that's
yeah you're here on a day with Emma
another uh Irish woman yeah
oh hell yeah we got there we go we got
someone signing up on a platter
we got the VIP treatment for someone
uh that's cool you guys uh have any
interest in pets or children would you
have children together
no oh so it works well yikes do you guys
have pets
no I do not I have five dogs your wife
has a pet yeah five dogs two cats
interesting details all the time five
dogs yeah and how do they like the magic
or are they more into the Jiu Jitsu yeah
yeah the Gaelic football we got older
dogs they're ready just to die
you know they're just they're just dying
age isn't that funny is five dogs about
to die
this is Jeffrey Dahmer of dogs yeah keep
them alive too long
what do you do with these dogs just keep
them alive give them love you know let
them sleep in the bed you know
yeah I mean that's why you're having
issues with your marriage that could be
five dogs no no I was joking about five
dogs in the bed we only have one that's
really close to us they got a bed dog
you were lying about the dog
I got five dogs wow that's really close
okay yeah the world's really close
though is racist
yeah he's always barking the ground and
snapping at me but it's really cool with
my black friends
oh that's a reversal yeah right that's a
joke I tried here I thought that would
be funny you're working a little bit
stop pointing please you're making the
crowd nervous
it's like Babe Ruth he points to where
the laughs aren't are about to die soon
you gotta call them out
um that's cool you have five dogs you
got one favorite yeah how do the other
dogs react knowing that you have a
favorite
well they know they're about to die so
they're kind of like just letting it go
like dude how old are these dogs man
one's like 14 you know yeah they're
pretty old ones like like 11. one have
we found on the street I don't know how
old it is but it's getting grayer so
gosh open relationships are a lot of
work yeah yeah he seems really excited
about his dogs
it's like the kids getting out of the
house it's great they're five they're
all about to die yeah can't wait less
dog food yeah yeah you don't have to
take on every dog that you see
but uh yeah that's cool Emma so how long
have you been in Austin two months two
months yeah and uh how do you like it so
far besides the dating part
I love it it's a lot of fun
easy to meet new people yeah yeah cool
dating shows yeah lots of dating experts
to help you along on a date with a
magician
um have you noticed like a lot of tech
workers here a lot of autism
yeah
definitely a lot of tech workers
well luckily chatto is uh quite
gregarious he works in the weed industry
he's not like all fuddy-duddy
he's loose he doesn't follow he doesn't
have a 401k to lose
just Carefree with his leather jacket
doing comedy
[Music]
I think I've run out of things to talk
about with you guys I appreciate you
brother yeah give it up forever
they started something
let's see how long it lasts oh we got
one in every bucket now
let's go with another woman man thing
one of those boring old straight
relationships
uh we got so Wiggy the man coming up
going on a day with the last woman
Cassidy
a female
a straight female
feel free to sign up
we need it
[Music]
one guy's gonna turn gay at the end of
this episode
we got one in the straight bucket one in
the gay bucket
we got swiggy and
yep the other person go on a date for
one minute starting now pick up the mics
and
go after it yo what's up hey yeah how
you doing I'm good how are you doing all
right hey yeah uh here with you all
right hey what are you into Anna oh I
don't know I guess coming to places I'm
not comfortable with and
eating and drinking with that you like
to eat and drink yeah I like smoking
weed chirping acid smoking DMT also
getting my ass licked on it it's like
salvamindu Anna that's open of you
I smoke weed too so that's cool yeah
you're pretty cute though thank you
appreciate it hey there bro
you from around here no I'm from New
Jersey I'm from like I'm used to this
I'm from like Delco oh okay yeah
familiar with your kind
you South Jersey not Central ah okay
what part and time give it up for
Cassidy and this can of Faygo that we
found
on the side of the street
wow Cassidy you said you're used to this
you go to a lot of ICP conventions
no
no I grew up in Jersey Jersey yeah
that's not far from Philly Philadelphia
like borders like Camden which is like
New Jersey yeah and then I also lived in
South Florida for six years so a lot of
the like oh my God she's saying
she's saying you're a meth head dude nah
I never really done math I don't know I
used to be addicted to heroin in like my
early 20s but I haven't really like done
that in like over 10 years then I'm
pretty clean so this is all natural this
is gross
oh my God he started laughing again
everyone started start a timer is this
gonna be as long as the last one because
I don't know well we can get another
dude up here you know we dudes are cheap
yeah
placeable
sweet
that's the thing he says his name into
the bike
Cassidy what's your uh experience with
uh you know like this like what have you
ever like seen one at a gas station yeah
like I had a couple live around the
corner from me that I start to know by
name and get familiar with so and they
give you like a bump of uh they always
tell me I look beautiful
in my pocket you're gonna snort some
mama okay the police station is right
across the street
please we do not want to get shut down
let's just keep it PG-13 swiggy
oh my God I feel like
it's like a horror movie
it was like that
that movie what is it nope
um Cassidy let's stick with the uh only
sane person on stage right now what did
what are you what normal job do you have
that's very normal
um I work in a hotel oh it's pretty
normal so excited to hear what his job
oh my God okay let's ask him hotel right
I have a pretty I work at Terry Black's
Barbecue I'm a cutter I like cut like a
brisket and like pork ribs and beef ribs
I put them on their plate and then like
I've been doing some crazy [ __ ] I'd be
tickling [ __ ] ribs like hot chicks in
the company like let me just tickle your
ribs real quick before I go on sometimes
I do it with the sausage let me get the
jalapeno cheese sausage I'm gonna go
tickle these ribs real quick sounds like
a jiu jitsu move
hey dude I tell them [ __ ] the chopped
beef is like El Chapo's like favorite
thing he eats because I [ __ ] do a
Taekwondo style karate chop before he
marries
let me get in on this action
before this we can switch you can have
more time with him if you want
Cassidy the bucket never lies
unfortunately
um I like music yeah no good yeah I can
rap a little bit I don't know I play
drums too whether you're not
swiggy asking a question that he wants
to answer himself a classic classic man
move do you play music I can rap
you ask every white woman if they can
rap
what's your success rate on that
well unfortunately Cassidy doesn't want
to hear you rap uh Cassidy what kind of
music are you into
um I like like relaxing music you know
swiggy is not your guy then yeah chill
y can you can you can you be uh can you
do any chill music chill music maybe I
don't know I probably on the drums
probably it when I get rapping that I
kind of I tend to get kind of hyped but
on it yeah I got like this podcast where
I'd be rapping on
Cassidy is 300 feet from here you can
rap
So when you say you tickle the meats
yeah dude what the [ __ ] yeah just look
at my fingers you know just like with
the ribs like pork ribs or beef ribs
tickle these ribs real quick if I put
them on your plate now sometimes like if
you want your ribs tickled again you can
just come up here and I'll take care of
where to avoid which Terry blacks do you
work at the one in Austin bro there's
only one in Austin I think there's like
a few others there's like one in Dallas
and they're opening one in Houston
pretty soon and there's one Lockhart as
well so he's telling us exactly where he
works
that's good information if you're
looking for me
for me at Fairmont all right okay okay
now everyone knows that reminder this is
live streamed on YouTube
Believe It or Not There Are People
weirder than swiggy online watching
right now
yeah
I've done a lot of online dating so I
just had to switch
and you got the same result yes pretty
much
it's just the people not the app
uh last time I met up with the chick
online she like came over my place and
after we [ __ ] like she wanted to smoke
by not having to eat I had like Wax and
then like I dabbed her out then she said
she was like oh hi then like I had this
DMT and I was trying to see if she
wanted to smoke it and she got like
wigged out and she left and then she
like ghosted me after that I don't know
boy it's pretty much I wonder where
maybe she died I don't know
I have it like a few months ago
hopefully she's still alive if you have
seen her
please call The Crime Stoppers hotline
we know where he works we can help you
Cassidy uh do you do drugs
um prescription drugs yes oh hell yeah
Percocet but apparently that's not a
drug weed is not a drug I think yes I've
heard otherwise now the LSD never done
LSD uh it's pretty cool yeah you'll
start rapping
maybe on it
so LSD you haven't done DMT Molly you've
never been to uh takashi69 concert
what kind of concerts do you go to
um the last concert I went to was the
Backstreet Boys hell yeah when they were
in town it was free so
wow free they're pretty old yeah now
swiggy would you be caught dead in a
Backstreet Boys concert nah uh maybe if
I was going with some chick that maybe I
don't know but I wouldn't go about
myself that'd be weird though why not oh
yeah you wouldn't want to be weird I
don't like the Backstreet Boys
it'd be like last concert who's probably
I think it's like fishing in a barrel
it'd be like fishing in a barrel for you
what kind of concerts do you go to ah I
like a lot of Grateful Dead concerts
fish concerts also like seeing like
hip-hop like uh like Wu-Tang stuff like
that or like Palmer Squares are pretty
cool or like uh like Funk groups I saw
like uh what's it George Clinton [ __ ]
but you had like his hair hair all
shaved I was expecting like the purple
dreadlocks but it was cool so you do the
same concerts that uh you can do drugs
too oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how I
probably got into like doing acid going
like Grateful Dead shows not really the
Grateful Dead it was like further it's
like Bob Weir and Phil Lester The
Grateful Dead but they were to be like
going on tour and like I remember I
followed him from like all the way from
like Philadelphia down to Florida then
out to Colorado and we were just like
dropping like [ __ ] these like white
fluff like dead hits like just like
tripping balls like most of the time I
was pretty well you can't trip like
every day we have to wait like at least
like a week probably in between each
trips to get like what a responsible
drug user you are yeah I did hey that's
something
at the Tony I'd be dropping it like
every Monday because the one time I
randomly got picked I like happened to
be tripping so I thought it was like
good luck or something so like I kept
tripping every night well what drug were
you on when you got the job you have
right now maybe you should yeah I was
sober bro I was in like job interview
swiggy that wasn't like regular swiggy
maybe we could see a little bit of that
I think Cassidy might be put at ease if
you pretended you're a human being
but that's like not really me though I
have to like like fake like I like being
myself I don't know you gotta be
yourself that's true
Cassidy what kind of drugs were going
around at this free Backstreet Boys
concert
[Music]
I guess
a lot of Xanax
that's cool good answer for that one did
you uh did you did you jam out is that
your thing the Backstreet Boys totally
rocked it you know 90s yeah that's cool
I bet you you do a sick rendition of
Wannabe by Spice Girls
I can't say I haven't before but it's
not my go-to karaoke song you know it's
the anthem yeah
you're kind uh so what college did you
go to are you a college student
um I went to Florida Atlantic University
oh that's right a bunch of swiggies yeah
they were all like five foot eight one
to be a DJ
South Florida men are winners for sure
yeah and you didn't do any drugs with
any of them no but I watched them and I
helped them because I'm a good person
it's hard not to watch when they're
doing it out in the street yeah
[Music]
um that's cool
and I have a question for swiggy uh when
when you're tickling the meat
is that uh is that like uh to help it to
like tenderize it are you just doing
that for fun yeah this thing's pretty
funny I don't know I'd be saying a bunch
of crazy shits I think it's funny you
know what's crazy is you can't even tell
the asset affected you at all I told
some people like uh that like like there
used to be like uh ancient ninja back
during the Ming Dynasty that would like
cut all the poor cribs or the katana
blade and like but we just use a
serrated knife it's not as cool I say
that to something like what like I don't
know I think people don't even call me
out on like [ __ ] Ming dynasties like
Chinese and like ninjas or Japanese like
I'm just like mixing [ __ ] up
thank you for disrespecting
got a joke at your job that no one gets
my ex-girlfriend did it to me once it's
pretty cool and I've had like a few
Horrors since then do it and it's pretty
wild but like it's definitely something
I'm into it's pretty cool when do you
usually bring that up on a date ah I
mean I thought it would be pretty funny
he's like I don't know but like at the
same time yeah I probably wouldn't bring
it up maybe the first night show but if
we were like fine I kind of went over
like one of your Ming Dynasty jokes yeah
it's cool
it's weird that on the first date you
wouldn't bring up getting your ass eaten
by multiple hookers that's um
I wish you had a wife crazy I know he
does it right into the mic
what's your favorite uh thing to laugh
at
uh what do you mean
wow this is a Charlie Rose version of
swiggy now we got Inside the Actors
Studio swiggy what what sets you off
what gets you going laughing for for a
minute uh man just like maybe personal
stuff or just I don't know just oh no
things like that and stuff on personal
stuff it's a little bit like if Seth
Rogen never got famous and just slowly
lost his mind
I'm kind of here for it yeah you seem
like a comedic genius what's like uh the
funniest thing that you've done oh
recently this is actually I don't know
this is the funniest thing I've done but
it's pretty recent I was like maybe a
few days ago I was on a date with some
chick I met or whatever and like we were
hanging out and then like things are
going pretty good and like she said she
was like that like she said something
like uh she like needed a place to [ __ ]
or something because like her lived in
with her brother or something I was like
well I got my own place and like she was
like yeah and she said she was down
we're all chilling all of a sudden I'm
sitting next to her and she's like
texting on her phone and I look down and
I see like a picture of like a dick I'm
guessing to some dude like dick picture
and she's like hit it real quick and
then like a few seconds later she told
me she had like other plans and like
didn't want to hang out I was like all
right
then she was mentioning that she had
like a boyfriend and like but I knew she
had a boyfriend before that and I didn't
think it was like an issue and I was
like what like I don't know like one of
those boyfriends
whatever
whatever French my friend
well that's cool what how good was this
dick were you intimidated or was it like
I only saw for like a few seconds I
don't know she's like hit it like oh no
I didn't really get like a good look but
I could tell what it was for a second or
two but I wasn't I'm not like in the
decks I don't Adidas okay let's get to
know he's straight
is that does that make you feel better
what the hell
what do you look for in a day Cassidy
I think it's very open of you that
you're like your ass eaten you know
most of the time you don't know until
you start to go a little bit
a little bit and then like and either go
ah or they're like oh I like that you
know so I was like good for you on that
one um lick your ass too I like I like
to eat [ __ ] as well okay
that's good
you have a technique yeah yeah I do like
the alphabet with my tongue over like
the [ __ ] areas and like you're down
liking the lips and stuff and then go up
and then like looking at the juices as
it leaks out like he's been near a
vagina before
I can tell he's using all the right
words so you like your ass eaten but you
don't like to eat ass
[Music]
Cassidy is there uh anyone you like to
call right now the police the FBI yeah
I'd like to phone a friend for sure
found a friend just don't show him a
picture of his dick
so it happens on his dates usually
what are you on right now or is are you
completely sober right now
I was smoking I did ketamine earlier but
I was like hour like a few hours ago a
few hours yeah Academy
in a few hours I have more in my pocket
but I was gonna I figured well I go to
academy and I feel like I can't really
do comedy because sometimes like I can't
really talk
like honest I feel like I should wait
till after I do the comedy to do more
yeah words are pretty important to
Comedy
whoa not to your comedy obviously you
just set him up and he just laughs he's
a good laugh track
Cassidy I'm so sorry uh
how do your dates normally go not you
know usually not this bad but not great
either so you know this is this is sort
of par for the course
dating scene yeah in a nutshell pretty
cute thanks Dad yeah we all it's you
that we're worried about really
hahaha
I like the last girl that he was on a
date with it was just like I need
somewhere to [ __ ] or something
no one is ever no woman has ever said
that I just need somewhere to [ __ ] I
just that's a crazy thing to say not
even like I need someone I'm chick who
is like really big like over like I
don't know 300 plus pounds and before
that I was with the chick who was like
like 48 years old though that's pretty
well okay lots of numbers right there
what's your uh favorite uh what what do
you look for in a date swiggy they're
honest having a good time I don't know
that's like chilling [ __ ] honest
honor this is [ __ ] chilling how does
anyone chill with a laugh like that
it doesn't go from chilling to worrying
uh but yeah so that's cool what's uh
what's what's the funnest date that
you've been on
front of the state I've been on
um
probably going to a hieroglyphics
concert with my ex and then she got all
[ __ ] up and then like uh of course she
got kicked out then I ended up having to
get out too but yeah it's pretty cool
double funk you I'm shaping like rap and
slipping that's called the New Jersey
mating dance right there
I've done that one a few times oh hell
yeah Backstreet Boys gets a little crazy
yeah get a little seltzer water in you
for sure that's cool what uh what other
concerts have you been to me yeah
um I've been to a lot of country
concerts yee-haw
um
I've been to I went to ACL actually so I
lied Backstreet Boys was not the last
concert I went to but okay other
festivals like Bonnaroo or no Burning
Man or Philadelphia Folk Festival no
okay
Philadelphia Folk Festival
the PFF yeah it did something like that
my dad goes in every year he's like the
electric man he's like a one-man band
thing he's like pretty wild on it like
it's pretty crazy he's like a legendary
it's like legendary dude it's like one
of the oldest festivals like oh it's
pretty well it's been going on since
like the early 50s or something like
this is that where you were conceived
possibly did yeah that'd make a lot of
sense
yeah
because you know Philadelphia they're
known for their folk music edit back in
the day probably on a legend there it's
not even in Philadelphia it's in like
Schwenksville and like some Farm like
outside of Philly but it's like pretty
close here so it's like all of his
stories are a matte lip or something
like that
there's a lot of details yeah you can
really recreate the whole scene yeah
this is a policeman's dream right here
yeah
everything you need to know
uh Cassidy how do you feel you feel safe
that's sort of the show
sorry that uh
someone had to go on a date with him he
did sign up I thank you so much for
taking the bullet sure you're an amazing
Sport and uh swiggy is now going to
leave you alone forever great well give
it up with Cassidy give it up for his
swaggy swiggy
the man the myth a legend
swiggy
we got two
people signed up
there's only two names in here you don't
have to sign up multiple times
uh well let's get Joey up here and then
let's get the only straight man left
it's Brandon
Brandon you're gonna go on a gay date
with Joey
and then then you got two women coming
up
so Joey and Brandon going on a date
and then Brandon's gonna get to go on a
date with a woman as a reward
but Joey is also a very very rewardful
person very beautiful man please give it
up for Joey and Brandon
[Applause]
pick up the mics and
start [ __ ] each other
how's your night going oh it's great how
about you
not too bad this is um this is a cool
scene you've been here before I have not
I literally I was on do 512 earlier and
I just happened to see it so it was
pretty cool no way yeah yeah my um hag
over there she wanted to come with me oh
oh that's awesome yeah that's why she's
sitting over there okay I didn't bring
anyone I just got just kind of showed up
because it was uh didn't have anything
to do nice yeah so what do you do I just
got out of grad school uh so I'm just uh
in between looking for jobs right now
that's impressive what'd you graduate in
uh chemistry oh well that makes me
stupid yeah no no no no no not at all
not at all oh that's awesome where'd you
go uh UT uh Longhorn fan there you go
for sure for sure
so how long have you been in Austin for
uh two years two years okay and we're
like where have you where have you been
around the United States
I grew up in Connecticut lived in Boston
for college lived in San Diego for five
years and I'm here okay cool yeah I was
in military brand so I was in Hawaii I
lived on the east coast in Virginia and
then my parents are in they're in the
midwest now and so it's not my favorite
place to be but it's okay so and then I
came here because I like Texas I don't
know what the Midwest is the Midwest
it's kind of plank in your mind
give it up for Joey and Brandon
wow we saved the most normal guy for uh
for a dude
because the girls they get they get
swiggy in Shadow but
Joey you got one of the most normal
people I've ever met a grad school
student from UT who majors in chemistry
you want to get married
I'm going to inherit a lot of money
not really
where did you inherit that fur coat from
um I actually bought it it was on uh
clearance at some store I can't remember
the name of it but it was for 20 bucks
wow Thrifty and stylish
thank you Brandon where did you get your
beanie from
[Laughter]
let's put the mic right on your chin
sorry yes
uh yeah you know I most of my shopping
is uh it's pretty much just online
shopping it's kind of what a digital I
know keyboard Warrior keyboard
exactly right yeah what's your Reddit
account it's been a while since I've
been on Reddit let's check your comment
history I just like to read them
actually it's more fun that way oh he's
a lurker and Twitter all the Twitter
comments too that's cool
so uh Joey what what do you think uh you
could assign Brandon as in a role like
if you were to go to an orgy with
Brandon like would he be the fluffer
would he be like it would be outside
watching is that what you think all gay
guys do
well I'd hope so I thought we're gay
that's why I'm curious yes so yeah what
you think the roles are in it
no way
okay as your first job you were like
let's see what it's like to be not white
yeah
and how did it go for you janitoring
well I learned how to wax floors really
well so
that's that's sort of like that's what
he'd be he'd be the waxer
like the Brazilian waxing for the men oh
wow you like it nice and shaved down
there
I guess hell yeah Brandon you're getting
nervous laughters
I know I'm getting close to something
what do you think Jordan I can't believe
how normally is compared to swiggy is I
know it's not that hard man crazy just
act like you pay taxes
and you can drive a car
what uh what's the best dates you guys
have been on best states
all my dates are the best
dog oh
that makes people want to date you more
I bet I think the best dates are like
when something like random happens like
I think like one time like I was just
going to put that mic right by your
chest sorry uh and then there's like a
random like trivia night that I didn't
know about and so it just turned into
like a trip it's going down again just
make it touch it touch your chin with
the men feel that cold metal how are we
doing now yeah that's great just imagine
you're at an orgy and you're waxing a
dick laughs
makes sense yeah no
um you know uh trivia your best date was
trivia yeah well
it's like unexpected like something
unexpected like it's like it wasn't too
planned and then it like it turned into
something else so that's kind of cool it
turns out it was a dude and you had a
good time
oh no he's doing the Laughing thing
again
uh Joey what's uh what how's how long
have you been in Austin how's uh Austin
treating you two years in Austin and I'm
loving it well what do you like so much
about it everything is really bigger in
Texas oh hell yeah
you talking about dicks
how did you know it's a feeling
it's a feeling like you're doing jiu
jitsu
uh Brandon how big is your dick oh
that's uh give him this be honest scale
don't make him actually I never wondered
about that personally how big does it
feel to you how big it's big enough and
that's all that matters on a scale of
three to seven inches
what do you think how like what's your
energy level like energy level yeah
energy is pretty good I'd say okay so
like five five and a half above average
okay above American average this is a
giant in Asia
um Joey what's uh what's been your uh
what's been your dating history like in
Austin you've met a lot of uh cute acute
straight men like Brandon I have
actually met a lot of straight men who
are interested in me
and I do drag and female impersonation
so I have a very specific look that a
lot of people are very like oh what is
that and then for me I'm able to be a
different part of my personality and I
love it so I didn't put all the makeup
on today because that cost a lot of
money
not trying for us on this show but
that's cool and a lot of these uh big
strong Texas Men actually wanna
[ __ ] a dude yeah you can just download
grinder and literally it's just like
ding ding ding ding it's like everything
Cassie give me my phone I can show you
we're gonna have a real life example
uh well thank you Governor Abbott for
creating such a hostile or a such a
beautiful environment for repressed
homosexuals
yes thank you
Brandon are you vaccinated oh yeah yeah
for sure oh so you do like things
penetrating your body
what's your dating history like with the
females
um I've been like three long-term
relationships and then you know you get
busy with life but you know that's just
how it goes Too Much Chemistry Too Much
Chemistry man it's just that's yeah
that's exactly it do you have a favorite
Beaker or Erlenmeyer class it's got to
be erlin Meyer man okay well this guy
knows the [ __ ] over a Bunsen burner
always [ __ ] so what are you doing with
chemistry haven't we all figured that
out by now
All I'm gonna say is that my stepdad
when he found out that I was going into
chemistry and I was moving down to Texas
he's just and I was so close to the
Border he was just like very
disappointed he's like Brandon I'm very
disappointed in you he thought you were
going to be the next Breaking Bad
exactly exactly and what are you doing
with your Chemistry skills yeah we're
gonna I'm doing some pharmaceutical
stuff actually oh nice that's a good
industry without any evil in it yeah
well you know
pays the bills what are you what drug
are you working on any drugs to make
swiggy turn back normal
uh well it's mostly cancer
oh oh a cancer wow good for you man you
get any [ __ ] with that I should open
with that next time
yeah it's like your grandma got cancer
not anymore
no chemistry [ __ ] I was gonna be so
mean to him when he said Pharmaceuticals
that was about to be so me but then
carrying cancer that's very yeah what a
sweet man yeah you can charge a premium
on that people will pay a lot of money
to cure cancer exactly you look like all
the characters are breaking bad yeah
okay okay A little Walter White little
Jesse pink man the one I usually get
actually I usually get uh Joe Goldberg
from you
so yeah see there's always somebody that
says it from you a Netflix show and have
you ever been to a drag show before I
have not no come over to my place okay
he's doing the laugh again I think I'm
just gonna say very nervous that's how
you know he's close to turn and Joey do
you have it
I mean you should see me with my makeup
on it would actually have you second
guess yourself for a split second and
then you'd be like nope you're good I've
only popped in a Cheer Up Charlie's for
about five minutes that's it and that
was it Cheer Up Charlie's that's it
that's it Cheer Up Charlie's that's it
it's the only gay bar you've ever been
to uh yeah I mean but you know we were
just popping in because we were just
checking out the whole okay no you have
to go to rain on Fourth
you gotta go dance on the disco light up
dance floor and everything gotta go like
literally start dodging people and
whatnot oh okay go to OCH oil can
Harry's make sure you go watch drag show
okay go see ritzy bits Cecilia light
okay they're like popular yes very
popular every week yes okay like every
Thursday go and do it do your homework
yeah you know how to chemically make
yourself into a woman so and do you know
how many women love going to gay bars I
was just about to say that actually you
could easily pick up someone I have
literally gotten 25 to like 30 of my
friends laid from going to a gay bar
holy [ __ ] let me go with you if that
doesn't want you Brandon you you can't
go anymore
getting your dick sucked either way so
that's good
that's awesome be careful of the
bathrooms oh okay yeah yeah don't tap
your feet hang a drink
gotta like cover it up the guys too no
just the girls no it's just the fact
that you want to make sure that nobody's
trying to sip it at the same time that
you're trying to oh yeah we have no idea
what's gonna go in there yeah that's why
I never stuck out of a straw I never
have that in my drink that's the only
reason you gotta watch your drink at a
gay bar yeah literally so many people
will be like
that sounds beautiful and straight bars
we got to watch our drinks for a
different reason
gay bars people are like why would I
drug them I could just ask them
[Laughter]
Brennan what's your uh game at a
straight bar what do you what's your
opening line what's my opening I don't
oh you know it's the thing I don't have
any openers I'm a nice guy yeah Joey do
you have it you need to fix that I need
to fix that yeah Joey do you have an
opening line that he can use me I don't
know I don't have an opening line I have
an opening look and that's about it try
dressing in full drag
can you give Brandon right here the the
opening look that you give people on
rain well not now I don't have my makeup
on
well you can give us a little little
teaser a little Glimpse okay so the way
you tell if a guy is into you is the
glare okay the stair okay they will look
at you okay so I'm gonna look at you
oh I saw that no I don't want you oh I'm
sorry Brandon it's a tough world out
there here's another look
that means we're going to meet in the
bathroom soon
that means uncover your drink
s
girl you wore that to the club
yeah Brandon this isn't really uh Gonna
Fly on 4th Street you uh you got more of
us uh 14th Street look about you yeah
right by the capitol but I'd say so yeah
Brandon what do what do you do what do
you do to get ready to go out to a club
like what's your look
it's my look oh yeah I'm more of like uh
like I like I lived in beaches for most
of my life so like I like like a good
idea
oh v-neck and khakis
wow you really do fit into Austin yeah
yeah you look like any other Tech bro
probably probably that's cool v-neck
khakis and you're like hey I'm just here
to chill have a good time yeah exactly
have a good night I also have a BMW out
front one of these days yeah
maybe Tesla
well would you like to go on a date with
a woman Brandon since you are straight
after all if we get some ladies together
maybe we can go to a drag show fun
well Joey thank you so much for coming
on this stage showing Brandon yeah a
little taste of the good side
red and stay right there we're gonna get
you what are these females that we've
collected in a bucket we got some of
these bucket females for you
we got Catalina coming up
Catalina I know your name
we got Catalina go on a date with
Brandon
a straight man
for now
[Music]
going a day with Catalina straight
female
for one minute starting now how's it
going good how are you
this is kind of cool
exciting I like your tattoo what do we
got here
entire lifetime is that like a gym
membership you're like you're here for
the entire lifetime like you can't leave
no no not at all okay very cool
I always thought like if I was gonna get
a tattoo it'd be something super nerdy
like it'd be like a DNA Helix
um I don't know it's just because I'm
kind of that's the kind of guy I am like
a Pokemon I don't know about Pokemon but
yeah something something chemistry
related maybe uh
um yeah Pokemon's cool too though yeah
yeah
definitely
how long have you been here for
um like six years six years okay about
the same for me awesome yeah how are you
from Midwest where Indiana
okay Midwest yeah yeah yeah it's back in
the middle I mean but uh it's a lot
warmer down here so
do you go to comedy shows a lot
yeah okay I haven't been since like
before 2019 and last one was cold Town
Theater I don't know if you guys know
coal town and time give it up for a
Catalina and Brandon
[Music]
I don't know what it is but a woman on
stage made you about five percent
creepier
let's get the gay guy back I think that
was your best side Brandon
I think we found your new calling
that's awesome
she's happy to be here you need to start
background checking the guys start
betting everybody yeah we don't want
just a bunch of brandons up here we need
a little swiggy in our life you know
what I'm saying comedians up here for
sure I'm sure gotta work on that improv
Brandon you started uh talking about our
tattoo entire lifetime turns out it was
not what you thought it was
did you think like maybe you could ask
her and she could tell you yeah what is
entire lifetime what is going on here
um I don't really like when people ask
about my tattoos but it's more of like a
you know just a reminder of like people
spend their entire lifetimes not doing
what they want like
what not like it's a little
a good reminder to
it's like a mantra like you say to
yourself or yeah we all die
okay yeah yeah that's cool that's cool
is that what you expected Brandon not at
all what I expected but uh yeah I feel
like most tattoos end up being like some
cool calligraphy thing so but uh no if
it's important to you that's the only
thing that matters it's like so what a
positive guy's a nice guy you should
feel good about your tattoo I wish she
already did but no Brandon it's also
encouraging you uh Brandon what do what
tattoos do you have
zero actually I you know I'd like to
find a tattoo place I don't know any
good ones what would you get
I know maybe like a it's like a dick
because you're gay now
is that what happens
[Music]
uh I don't know like maybe something
cheesy like uh like an anchor or uh an
anchor why because you like dick so much
you're a sailor no yeah like sale like
something something beachy I don't know
what would be like beaches beachy Bad
are there a lot of beaches in Indiana
not in Indiana but I I'm also from uh
Oahu in Virginia too
oh [ __ ] I don't know Oahu was in
Virginia he's from definitely not
Mahala
just going down to Quantico to destroy a
third world nation
catch you later dude
I love that
that's cool what do you like to do in uh
Oahu
you know it's been so long uh just check
out all the you know the touristy places
go hiking uh eat lots of good food
okay
Catalina have you ever been to Oahu
both Islands I have not but I have been
Hawaii yes have you been to Catalina
I have not
he's from L.A
it's an island Catalina do you know
about Catalina yeah that's what I'm
named after
well yeah
they did a spot-on job naming you after
that thing it's almost identical well
it's a nice Island so you should go
sometime
what's what's the difference between
Oahu and Catalina
I I'm confused as to why we're talking
about uh your name as
because we're interested in who she is
instead of just talking about ourselves
the whole time like you did okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry it's a little
bit a little bit selfish no for sure for
sure uh I don't know I need to go to
more Islands I guess
yeah go around different Islands
what what uh what brought you to Oahu
what got you over there I'm a military
brat actually oh so you're a station
there with your dad is stationed there
from there yep just kind of moving
around a lot as a kid yeah cool did you
uh
kill anyone didn't kill anyone but I can
still hula hoop and I've won a few
contests in Austin actually that's close
to killing someone
killing them with boredom Brandon's good
at hula hoop Catalina do you like hula
hooping would that turn you on if
Brandon started hula hooping
I need a few more drinks for that
you're having so much fun up here
what if you started hula hooping with
this five and a half inch [ __ ] wow that
would be pretty impressive yeah what
then
insane Catalina what do you do for a
living
oh
swimming in cash
what uh what do you do for this
executive
[Music]
everything
sounds like a little Joey and Brandon
action going on
uh Joey was the last guy that was on
Brandon it's this guy
um
Catalina how do you like uh being so uh
be working in that job do you enjoy that
that environment
yeah I love it it's very casual and very
strange
um and interesting
why is it strange
um I mean I do across the board I
you know
book private jets and all that but I
also am like taking the hair out of your
hairbrush
and private jets what does your boss do
a lot of stuff but stock trading
hmm
well 31 very secretive he's carrying
cancer usually it's the other way around
it's usually the woman that does
something good for the world but that's
true I guess you're destroying the world
wasting jet fuel to get the stock Trader
to Oahu
and you've also been on a private job
okay we don't need to compare our carbon
footprints
photos of you on private jets
uh Brandon have you ever been on a
private jet before I have not loser
sorry
working on it man working on it what's
uh what's your job do you have a job yet
working at a startup right now actually
it's uh we do a lot of machine learning
stuff okay so it's like big Tech Machine
learning he's working at a startup about
this yeah he's curing cancer at a
startup that's where all the cancer
curing happens
um what do you like about your little
job that
oh okay
it's remote and it pays well and I can
still live in Austin because Austin's
like the coolest city on earth so oh
yeah that's great you know yeah no one
else agrees but uh well we all
appreciate that you're here
and Austin killing it with chemistry
you're actually doing stuff sure but
that's cool yeah Catalina's uh an
executive assistant you
live the high falling lifestyle looking
down on working stiffs like Brandon uh
what the what what's the most normal
thing that uh your little uh executive
does
we do puzzles together
wow that's fun yeah well we're out of
time
thank you so much for coming up Catalina
and Brandon thank you
thank you guys for coming uh Jordan you
got anything you want to plug nope all
right check him out drunk white boy on
Instagram very funny comedian we just
been touring all over the place my name
is Hans Kim we just watched some people
find out that they are going to be
single forever so luckily it's not you
guys uh had a great time thank you guys
so much for coming out good night